- My next guest is a former
monk turned bestselling author.
That doesn't happen every day.
His podcast "On Purpose with Jay Shetty"
is the number one health
podcast on the planet.
He's interviewed everyone
from President Biden to Oprah Winfrey.
He's even interviewed the
man sitting next to me
that can sing, lies and deception.
Please welcome Jay Shetty, everybody.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
(bright jazzy music)
(crowd continues applauding)
You, I have to lead with this,
you have the most beautiful eyes ever.
They are like-
- Oh, thank you.
- so beautiful.
- Well I can't take any
credit for them, so-
- Okay, well done god.
Have y'all met before?
You know each other, right?
- Yes, yes.
- Obviously?
Okay, okay.
- Yeah, I've had the fortune of-
- We just met in person.
- We did, just earlier
today.
- Just earlier today.
- Oh!
- But I've had Dwayne
on the show, and we actually
did it virtually through Zoom.
- Yeah.
- And, the connection
was bad and all this kind of stuff.
- Terrible.
- But his spirit
still came through, so it was beautiful.
You were phenomenal.
- Yeah, it was great.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Have you always been
good at public speaking?
- Definitely not.
- Okay.
I'm, I get nervous speaking.
- Oh my gosh.
I need to tell you a story
about my first ever time public speaking.
I was seven years old.
There was an assembly at
school, a cultural assembly,
and my mother loved to see me on stage.
So she dressed me up in a
traditional Indian outfit,
parts of me were falling out.
And then she'd asked me to sing,
I have a horrific singing voice.
She'd asked me to sing
something in my native language
on stage in front of my school.
So I get up there, I start singing,
and talking and singing.
And everyone bursts
out laughing, everyone.
- Ugh.
- I'm glad you didn't
start laughing right now.
And then, I forgot the words
so I looked down to see
if I could read the words,
and I couldn't because my
tears had smudged the words.
(crowd gasps)
And so then I forgot the words
and everyone started laughing more.
- This is the worst story ever.
(crowd laughs)
- Yeah.
And then, to make it worse, my teacher
came on stage and put her arm around me.
- Oh no.
- And walked me off stage.
(crowd awing)
And that was my first experience
of public speaking, so...
(crowd laughing)
- And you're, here you are now.
This is incredible.
- Yes, you can do anything.
- I know, I'm just saying like the fact
that that didn't deter
you, and you were like
I've got this!
- Oh my gosh.
Yeah, it was painful.
- I don't know if I'd ever
speak in public again.
- I know. That's what it felt like.
- Well Jay spent three
years as a Hindu monk,
and later wrote a bestselling book,
called "Think Like a Monk."
So you've talked a lot
about why you became a monk,
but not why you maybe got out.
So why? What was the reason?
- Well, I was learning just
so many incredible insights
about mindfulness and meditation.
And I really had this hunger
and desire to share it with the world.
But at the time, now it makes sense.
But back then, I was actually quite scared
when I came back to London.
And I was stuck about where to start.
And I remember talking
to one of my mentors
and saying, I have so many
ideas about how to help people,
but I don't know how to get started.
And I'm guessing some of you
have felt that way before.
And he gave me some brilliant advice
I'd love to share with you.
- Yeah.
- He said to me that Jay, you should try
and open every door you possibly can.
Some of the doors will close on you
and you should let them close.
But the doors that remain open,
those are the ones that are meant for you
and you should keep walking through them.
And I feel like I'm sitting here today
because I've just continued
to walk through the doors
that stayed open for me.
- Yeah.
Rather the ones that shut on my face.
(crowd clapping)
- I mean, you can use that
in so many different ways.
- Absolutely.
- Like relationships, like everyth.
You can use that, it's a great metaphor.
And it's that time of year when some of us
have started off with
really good intentions,
and plans to make pivots in our lives.
Not me, I'm conquering them all.
But some of you may have
lost a little steam.
We have several people in our audience
with questions about
their life pivots for Jay,
so let's answer some of those right now.
Bailey has a question
about moving forward.
So Bailey, go ahead.
- Hi, Jay.
- Hey Bailey.
- My name is Bailey, and I was diagnosed
with brain cancer and the age of 24.
So I had about a year and a
half going through treatment.
And during that time, I listened
to your podcast all the time.
I listened before, but I extra
listened during all of that.
And so, you know, that was a really,
my life was put on pause for a little bit.
And then, I finished my treatment.
I'm now 26.
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Yeah, so now I'm 26 and I'm
going back to the real world,
kind of, my new real world, I should say.
I'm in grad school.
And, I had like some
different questions to ask you
because kind of like
my life was put on hold
for a little bit, while
everyone else my age
in their twenties was moving forward,
I was kind of on pause.
So I'm wondering if you had any advice
when you go through like
a setback in your life,
how to move forward from it?
And how to, what's the
best advice to you got?
- Oh my God, that's a huge question.
It's a good one.
- Bailey, wow, first of
all, you're so inspiring.
Like listening to you is inspiring,
(crowd clapping)
honestly.
That's unbelievable, it's unbelievable.
I was about to run up the steps and try
and give you a hug, but I
don't think it's possible.
But, maybe later.
But honestly, listening to your
story makes me realize that
what it sounds like you're
dealing with is grief.
And a lot of us think of grief
as loss of someone we love,
but grief can also be the
loss of a life we once had,
or a time we thought we should
have had or could have had.
And I was speaking to
Katie Couric yesterday,
and she shared this really
beautiful thing with me
that I'd love to share with you.
She was saying to me that grief is like
walking around with a rock in your pocket.
And she was saying that in the beginning,
every time you move, you feel that rock.
It might even scratch you, it hurts you.
And then she said, as time goes on,
the weight of that rock
starts to feel less and less and less.
It's not that it goes away.
And, it goes less and less and less
because you are growing at the same time.
And I think one of the
best ways you could grow,
and I'd love for you to try this,
is keep sharing your
inspiring stories with others.
I think if you're helping other
people carry their weight,
then your weight starts to feel less.
So I hope you'll try that out.
And keep inspiring Bailey,
your story's phenomenal,
genuinely.
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you so much, I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much, big hugs.
Big air hugs.
(crowd continues clapping)
- I do think it's nice that you're saying
to shift your focus on others,
if you're going through a
hard time, it helps a bit.
- Absolutely.
- Not the escapism of it,
but just to lessen its power.
- Yes, yes yes.
- You know? Yeah.
Thank you so much Bailey,
and congratulations, man.
(audience applauding)
That's a huge thing, that
happens in your life.
Well Headier has a question
about navigating rejection,
which I think we all relate to.
- Hi Jay, I'm Headier.
So a little bit about
me, I'm 25 years old.
I just graduated pharmacy
school two years ago.
And in that time, I still have
yet to find a permanent job.
My mom and my dad tell me
to put myself out there,
to ask friends, to apply
at different locations.
But unfortunately, I just feel stuck.
I feel tired, I feel left behind.
And I don't, I have a
fear of asking for help.
I have the fear of rejection
from like the hospitals and other places.
So I just don't know what to do.
- Actually, I wanna role play a little bit
right now, if you're okay
with it.
- Yeah, of course.
- So can we get a little ringtone sound?
Yes?
♪ Ring ring ♪
- There you go, perfect.
- Hey Headier, it's Jay. How's it going?
- Hey Jay, how you doing?
- I'm doing really well,
I'm doing really well.
What's up?
- Nothing much.
- Well, I heard that you graduated
a couple of years ago.
How's it all going?
- Oh you know it's
going, just living life.
- Is there anything I could do for you?
- I don't know, I don't know what to...
(audience laughs)
I truly,
I guess maybe help me contact,
if you have connections
that can help me, I guess.
- Yeah. And what kind of
connections would you need?
- In hospitals.
That's where I'm mainly
looking at right now.
- That's brilliant Headier.
I'm gonna reach out to
my network, for real
and see what I can do for you.
So thank you so much
Headier for asking for help.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I appreciate it.
Well done.
Thank you. It wasn't so hard, right?
(crowd clapping)
It wasn't so hard?
- It's so funny because
I love how you started
because I, that is the thing,
I think a lot of us have a hard time with.
Like, I'm always there,
like I love helping people,
but it is very hard, I had
to learn how to be able to...
'Cause I think sometimes we think
it's a sign of weakness or something.
- Yes.
- And it's not.
- We think we're taking
something from someone.
But actually, you're
giving them an opportunity
to shed kindness, to spread kindness.
- Mm.
- And anyone
who wants to do that is gonna take it
as an opportunity to want to support you.
- Yeah.
- And so,
I want you to try that out.
Just practice it a few more
times and you'll nail it.
- Thank you so much Headier,
just for sharing.
(crowd clapping)
- Yeah, thanks Headier.
- And good luck.
Maybe someone listening right now
on TV heard that.
- I know.
- She would make a great
employee at a hospital,
I'm just saying.
Well On Purpose with Jay Shetty
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
Jay is also the Chief Purpose Officer
for Calm, an app where you can find
his daily mindfulness
series, so check it out.